Um, and I'm sure you guys
know why we're all here today.
I'm bringing in my good buddy Michael
Block to talk about a game that he
developed and titled,
we asked Chicago which details the life
of a teenager growing up in a rough part
Chicago and the different instances that
he goes through and decisions that he
has to make in order to
protect himself and his family.
But before we get into that, I'm
just going to go through, you know,
a quick personal story about
myself. Um, and then after that,
and Michael will go through some of the
creative process of going through the
game.
Okay.
So we live in a time we're witnessing
overwhelming amounts of violence is the
norm.
It seems like we can't look at our Twitter
feeds or Facebook timelines without
viewing violent content.
Not only does the world appear to
be becoming a more violent place,
but it also seems as though we have video
evidence of nearly every violent event
with so much negativity
and violence in the world.
It's difficult to not fail
anger, sadness, or even fear.
Gun violence in particular has been
a constant theme in a new circuit.
As of late,
everything from terrorist attacks to
police shootings to random murders,
two school shootings appear to happen
way too frequently for most people.
These are just events that come and go,
but to some of us,
they hit a little closer to home.
It really affect us on a personal level.
For instance,
May 31st,
2015 was a day that
changed my life forever.
I was coming from a wedding in
Cincinnati with my now fiance.
When I got a call from a family member,
it letting me know that my little
brother had just been shot and killed in
Chicago. Um, it was a very
difficult situation, a process.
Um, so many thoughts ran through my
head, you know, how did this happen?
Why did this happen?
Um,
I don't know what I would've done without
the love and support of friends and
family members there in this
difficult time. You know,
we were all there for each other in a
way that we weren't necessarily prepared
to be, but that we had to
be. And obviously, you know,
at first we went through
feelings of overwhelming sadness,
but eventually we got to a point where
we could talk about my brother's life and
remember all the good times and smile.
Um,
so you know,
different things are going to happen
in our lives that will affect us in a
negative way, but it's
important to, you know,
remain positive and keep pushing forward.
So fast forward to May,
2016 a year after my brother passed and
a month or so after I started at Google,
I was speaking with my mother about
ways to honor my brother's life,
when literally the next day I got a new
hire email from Google letting me know
that I just received a
$10 donation voucher.
The timing couldn't have
been any more perfect.
Literally that same day I donated to the
Educational Fund to stop gun violence,
which is a group that I've been pretty
active in ever since helping to raise
both awareness and money for that group.
But really that just led me to
realize how fortunate, you know,
I am to work at such an amazing company,
a company that really promotes diversity
and encourages us to volunteer and to
donate to different organizations.
And we'll even match our donations on our
behalf. You know, cause the most people,
Google is a great place because we have
cool offices or great technology or free
food. But really it's the people that
make the biggest difference, you know?
And that goes for any company really,
you know,
it's each and every one that you guys
would make the biggest difference there.
So with that being said,
I encourage each and every one of you
to be the positive force in the lives of
those around you.
So say hi to someone new.
Say how's it going to someone you know,
respond in a timely manner to
your friends, text messages,
you know, smile more,
give more high fives and most importantly,
just be,
just be a better person, you know?
And also I wanted to just recognize,
you know, what a unique opportunity,
you know, Michael's game is.
I feel like we all hear so much about
the violence that's going on throughout
the world in Chicago
particularly. And you know, we,
we hear that on the news
or different articles,
but this is just a unique way to present
that to the public and sort of raise
awareness about it.
So with that being said,
I do want to kick it off to Michael
Block to talk about sort of the creative
process and different things that were
involved in the creation of this game.
[inaudible]
thank you for that.
And stories like that.
We're the reason that we started
working on this project. Um,
I'm skipping around a little bit my
slides because this is a little a day of,
we'd kind of changed the
order of this, but, um,
we were doing volunteering and we heard
stories like Antonio's a over and over
again from people on the south
side, uh, about their experiences.
And that was the,
the huge motivating factor behind starting
this project and trying to talk about
things in a more personal light, uh, and,
and sharing the kind of personal stories
of people who have to deal with these
situations and aren't
seeking out violence in arch,
aren't trying to get involved in things
but get dragged into them anyway. Um,
and so that's, that's kind
of the focus of the game. Uh,
so I'm going to get back to my slides.
Um, so, hi everyone. I'm Michael.
Uh, and I've been in game development
for about seven years. Uh,
and I've been in Chicago for about 10,
so I'm not from Chicago.
I'm from Wisconsin originally,
but I've been here for a while and
I've always lived on the north side of
Chicago.
Uh,
and that gave me a particular experience
in a particular kind of worldview about
the city. Um, and something that,
this project kind of changed in my
mind about how I see the city now.
Um, and I've been the project
lead on, on this game. So, uh,
kind of, uh, a brief overview of,
of what the game is in general. A,
so the entire game is driven through
kind of conversation choices.
So you're able to make choices,
think of it like a choose
your own adventure book, uh,
where you're deciding how
to respond to things in,
in conversation with
characters, and then, uh,
they in turn change the story and kind
of respond to you in the appropriate way.
Um,
so today I'm going to go through kind
of our process for developing that game,
uh, and some of the research
that we went through,
the pre production and the design choices
that we had to make throughout the
process that we're kind of unique to our
game. And then I'm going to talk about,
uh, some of the lessons
learned. So we released the
game last week. Uh, it's been,
it's been out for one week and so we
have some kind of preliminary information
about how people are responding to the
game and things that have worked and
things that maybe haven't
worked as well as we had hoped.
And so I wanted to kind of share
that with you as well. Uh, so, uh,
to begin with our development process.
So at the beginning,
we are just generally talking about how
do we tell a true story and a game. Uh,
typically with games, the player has
agency and they can make choices.
And if you're making choices about
something that actually happened,
that can potentially break
what actually happened.
And so we were trying to wrap our minds
around how can we implement a true story
in a game and, and maintain, uh, the
accuracy of the story without, uh,
taking away all of the players'
choices. Um, and at the same time, uh,
we were doing some volunteering
and this particular day, uh,
it was community action day and basically
everybody who was involved fanned out
across the city to various
public transit stops, uh, and,
and other places in neighborhoods
on all sides of the city. Uh,
and we basically interviewed people on
the street and ask them what they were
experiencing in their neighborhoods,
what were the good things,
what were the bad things?
And in this particular instance,
it was how can this nonprofit kind
of help your neighborhood and provide
opportunities for you?
And what we heard a standing at the red
line stop on 63rd street was a lot of
similar stories about, uh, sorry,
a lot of similar stories about,
um, people getting mugs or people
getting held up at gunpoint. Uh,
and they could point to, you know, this
street corner or that Ali, uh, and,
and talk about their experiences
personally that they,
they had experienced or things that
their friends had experienced. Uh,
and we knew that these were
kind of commonalities among,
among all their stories,
and they were, uh, something that
wasn't being talked about as much, uh,
from this personal angle in
media and news and TV. Uh,
and we thought this was a really,
um,
important thing to be talking about and
something that would fit very well, uh,
in the context of a game where you're
having to interact with things and you're
having to make choices and understand a
character's intentions and reasoning, uh,
as opposed to just watching something
play out or we're passing judgment on
somebody because they made a choice. Um,
you have to actually make the choice.
So we were talking to our
volunteers, uh, that were,
that were with us at the 63rd street stop
and they were super excited about the
game and they were from the south side
and they were like, we want to help,
how can we help?
Uh,
and so we followed up with them and
did one on one interviews with them and
really went in depth about
their experiences growing up,
talk to them a lot about the specific
situations that were very kind of
influential in their lives.
And then we kind of got referrals
to their friends and their friends,
their friends. And so we got
this kind of expanded network of,
of one on one interviews that
went much more in depth. Uh,
and then, uh, we started
looking for a writer. Uh,
so during this process we were
kind of reaching out to people to,
to see if we could find a writer who
was from the south side and could,
could really bring their
personal experiences and
their understanding of growing
up in these neighborhoods
to the game itself. So, uh,
we took those interviews,
uh, and we were, you know,
working on these on our own and trying
to kind of find the commonalities in them
and, and really figure out what
the game was going to talk about.
And we were doing outreach to
colleges and I found, uh, Tony, uh,
through Kennedy King College,
which is in Englewood, uh,
by just reaching out to English
professors and saying, Hey,
we've got a game and we need somebody to
work on it. Would anybody be interested?
And we got in touch with Tony and he grew
up in Englewood and he raised a family
and Englewood.
Uh,
and he had kind of all of the perspectives
that we were talking about in the
game. So you're playing as a teenager, but
you have parents and your parents have,
you know, a lot of concerns
of their own, about, you know,
what choices you're making and the
things that you're doing in your life.
And so he kind of had the perspective of,
of growing up in this and also
raising a family in this. So, uh,
he was able to kind of present all of
the perspectives that we were looking for
a in the game. The caveat was, uh,
that he wanted to do film and he wasn't
particularly familiar with games.
Uh, and so we were like, okay, we can make
this work, this is going to be fine. Uh,
but there was a lot more kind of learning
process than we originally expected,
um,
from transitioning from kind of a linear
storytelling to branching dialogue and,
and multiple choice options
and things like that. So, uh,
a lot of the early production,
you get to see some real early shots here.
The early production was a lot
of iteration with Tony, uh,
to kind of hone in on what choices
were interesting in what choices were
compelling and what things you
could give to the player that,
that kept them interested in the
story and kept them engaged. Uh,
and that iteration a, it took a little
bit longer than we thought, but it was,
it was worth it, uh, to make sure that
the things that we were representing,
word being done well and being accurate
to the, the stories that we had heard.
Uh, it also resulted in us coming to some
realizations that we wouldn't have had,
uh, had Tony not come
onto the project. Um,
and is a scene from the
game. Uh, so to set this up,
your sitting down at a table with your
family and one of your friends from
school and a gunshot is going to go off
outside and they're going to react in a
certain way. Uh, so I'll talk
about it more after that.
Janice is ready.
Come sit down and let's bless the food.
Bow Your heads.
Dear Lord,
we thank you for the meal we are about
to receive and we thank you for life,
family and friends.
Amen.
Was that a gunshot? Everyone stay
seated and don't go near the windows.
I'm so tired of all these shootings.
It's like we're prisoners
in our own houses,
lots of base. Uh, so,
so when we were originally
approaching this, uh,
we wanted to talk about
gunshots, obviously, uh,
that was kind of the focus of the scene.
Um,
but our original thought about how this
was going to go was that there was a
gunshot going off outside and people were
going to be afraid of it or they were
going to get upset. Um,
and, and talk about it.
And when we were talking to Tony about
how this scene was going to play out,
he was like, well, that wouldn't happen.
People in these neighborhoods are, are,
have grown accustomed to this,
to the point where if the gunshot
sounds far enough away from your house,
you're not going to have a reaction in,
in this. Like, you know, explicit way. Uh,
you'll recognize that it happened,
but you're not going to necessarily
bring it up and change what you're doing
because of it.
If it seems like it's far enough away.
And so that presented a problem
for us because, uh, making a game,
uh,
you,
you can get into a situation where the
player doesn't realize that something is
supposed to play out in a certain way.
So if the characters didn't react at all,
everyone would basically just assume
that we messed up and we made the game
wrong or there's a bug or something
happened and for some reason no one
responded. And that would
be really strange. So we had
to come up with a solution,
that kind of message to the player
what was supposed to be, um, you know,
a normal event was actually normal to
these characters even though the player
was likely not to think that
it was a normal event. Uh,
so we did a lot of iteration with him
and the solution that we kind of came to
was having Taylor bring up the
issue as a kind of frustration.
She wasn't afraid of it.
She was just frustrated that it's still
happening and that it continues to
happen.
And that allowed us to kind of get
into this discussion and have the wider
discussion without,
uh,
making the characters do something that
was out of character or, or seeming, uh,
to not represent those characters the
way that they would react in the real
world.
Um,
so those sorts of realizations we wouldn't
have come to had Tony not been on the
team.
And I think it was,
it was super important that we got
someone from the neighborhoods who work on
the writing for the games for this reason,
so that they could point out to these,
these important things that we needed to
talk about and that could kind of pass
on this realization and this
found knowledge to the player, um,
and figure out ways to message
that instead of just kind
of skipping over it. Um,
so this comes down to knowing
what's ask, right? Um, and it's,
it's all about our assumptions.
And we did interviews,
we did lots of in depth things to
find out what was happening in these
situations. But in a lot of,
a lot of those interviews,
the questions that we were asking were
based on kind of our assumptions that we
had made previously. And so that got us
to certain questions but not to others.
And that I think,
uh,
is one of the many reasons why having
a diverse team creating products is a
super important. Right. Um, yeah.
So another thing that
kind of came out of this,
this close iteration with Tony and also
with an artist that we brought on who's
from the south side as well,
a is a subtler things that we were able
to place in the environment that have a
huge impact on the kind of psychological
effects of playing the game.
Uh,
and things that people had talked about
when we were interviewing them and doing
one on one interviews,
uh,
that were psychologically impactful
on their lives growing up in these
neighborhoods. Um, so in this scene, uh,
there's this red x on this house,
uh,
and for one the house is
boarded up as well. Uh,
but there's also this red x on the house.
And if you've seen that before, uh,
or if you haven't,
the red x is a sign that says this
building is marked for demolition and it
means that this will be demolished,
but it hasn't been yet.
So essentially the
building is condemned and,
and ready to be demolished and it's just
sitting there being an eyesore. Right.
Um,
and the psychological impact as we
were talking to Tony and other people,
uh, of walking through your neighborhood
and seeing a building like this on every
block and seeing vacant lots
on every block, um, has a,
has a psychological impact growing
up in those neighborhoods. And, and,
and having to walk past
those things all the time.
And we wanted to kind of pass that along
to the player to give them a sense of,
of what are the impacts that people have
growing up in these neighborhoods. Um,
so that was one of the things that we
included. And then this other one is, uh,
an another example is this a
bulletproof glass in a restaurant.
So you go to work in a restaurant, which
is kind of like a fast food type place.
Um,
and it has bulletproof glass
and an exchange window so
that you can get the food
to the customer, uh, without having
to go outside the bulletproof glass.
And this, we don't explicitly talk about
this. We don't explicitly talk about the,
the red x sign, um, beside a
couple like passing comments in,
in some side dialog.
And the point was more to just have
these things exist in the world and have
people be confronted with them and have
to think about them. Right? Uh, and,
and this sort of thing is
something that is totally,
so it would be very strange
for the characters to come
out and talk about it. Um,
but it's something that if you're
playing the game and this is not your
experience, it's a very odd
thing to have in a restaurants.
Uh, and so it naturally starts to
raise questions about why it's there.
So another really early shot,
I don't know if these are even visible
as, as really early shots, but yeah. Uh,
so in the beginning, uh,
the art was very, very,
very scaled back to be really rough.
We were trying to get this
game done in a year. Uh,
and we intentionally said like, okay,
we want it to be realistic generally,
but we're going to be very,
very rough with the,
the visuals because we were a small team
and we don't have as much money to fund
a bigger project. And as
this screenshot shows, uh,
when you try to do that with
realistic human characters, uh,
it looks really strange and people get
really weirded out by your characters. Uh,
we had a lot of play tests early
on where we were like, hey,
we just want to know if the story is
good. Like, just tell us about the story.
We know the characters aren't ready yet.
We are not,
we know that they have work to be done.
People would just be like,
I can't the characters, I
just, I don't know what to,
I can't do anything with this. I like
just the store. Okay. Whatever. Uh,
so a lot of those design choices that
we made early on about being very
realistic, um, they were intentional.
We wanted them to be realistic because
we wanted the player to have as few
excuses for
disregarding what was happening in
the game as possible. So if they,
if they saw a cartoony visual
style, they might go, oh,
well this is an approximation and
that's not what everybody experiences or
that's not a thing that's,
that's realistic. Um,
and we wanted people to
have as few of those, um,
kind of reasons to be skeptical
about the content of the game.
So we made these choices intentionally,
but they got us into this
kind of iterative improvement
loop where we needed to
keep improving the visual so
that people started to, uh,
relate to the characters and not be
like turned off by, by the depiction.
Um,
so the project's balloon to a four year
project from the original one year,
uh, hope, uh, to get the
game done in a year. Um,
and that caused a lot of extra work,
but I think it was,
it was worth it in the end.
Uh,
so we took the game to a number of
conventions and this was where we were
getting a lot of our feedback.
And the first one that we went to
was a convention in Indianapolis. Uh,
and the first group of
kids at the booth was from,
we're from the south side of Chicago.
Uh, and so this is kind of our, our,
um, trial by fire here, right? We,
we hadn't demoed it publicly before and
here was a group from the south side who
would be able to speak to you whether
it was accurate and representative and
fitting with their experience.
Um,
and the kids immediately got excited
and they started talking about how the
house looks like their house and their
friends and everybody that they knew.
And they were really, really,
really, really excited about it. Um,
and that was super validating
and rewarding and we got
a lot of good feedback
from them. Uh, in subsequent shows, uh,
we started demoing it in Vr, uh,
because we had this, you know,
people keep talking about Vr as
an empathy building, a device,
I guess, inexperience,
uh, enhancement. Uh,
and so we were like, okay, let's try it.
Let's see if this is actually effective,
if it does actually lead
to more engagement and more
interest in the subject
matter. Um, and uh, we had
an interesting experience.
Uh, the kids that I'm going to be talking
about are not the kids pictured. Um,
they approached the booth and started
making some very insensitive and racist
jokes about the characters. Um, there
were other people playing on the,
on the TVS at the time and they didn't
really have any interest in the game,
but they saw the Oculus at the end of
the table after they've made their jokes
and then went, oh, when Oculus, I want
to play an oculus. So I was like, okay,
well sure, we'll sit you down and play
the Oculus. There wasn't anybody playing.
So they played for about five minutes
each kid and they subbed out and after the
first kid played for five minutes,
he got up and started talking about
the characters as if they were people.
And he started talking about them in
very nuanced ways and talking about the
problems that they were having.
And he was,
he basically pulled a full one 80
in the course of about five minutes.
Um, and there's so many things
that are specific to the situation.
It's at a conference.
He standing next to the developer.
There's lots of reasons
why that could happen,
but it didn't necessarily feel
like it was all, you know,
you're standing next to a developer
and don't want to say something bad.
It felt like a lot of it did actually
come out of a better understanding and in
an engagement with, with
the subject. So, um,
that gave us a little bit of hope
that the game was actually going to be
effective at what was originally
kind of our, our hope of,
of changing people's minds about people
living in these neighborhoods and,
and trying to increase empathy
and educate people. Um, and it,
it gave us hope, uh, you know, it's
again, a conference setting and,
and that sort of thing. So, uh,
now that we've released, uh,
what have we learned? So the
game came out last week, uh,
and we're gonna be doing other things, but
here's some, some preliminary findings.
So our goals primarily,
uh,
we wanted to create a respectful and
realistic depiction of a particular story
of growing up on the south
side of Chicago. Um, and again,
another thing that Kinda came out
of our development process was this
understanding of trying to break down the
idea of monolithic representation, uh,
and,
and really trying to present all these
different possible ways that people have
responded and,
and did respond when we were talking to
them in interviews to various situations.
So not everybody responds to a
gunshot going off in the same way,
and not everybody responds to
getting held up the same way.
So we wanted to depict that
too, to add to the, um,
discussion about monolithic
representation. Uh,
in addition,
the point of the game is to start in the
players and to get them talking about
the things that are happening in the game
and, and their impact on those things.
Uh,
we had these long term hopes that those
discussions would lead to people having
these thoughts when they're voting and
when they're thinking about politics and
when they're thinking about, you know, uh,
supporting nonprofit works
or things like that. Um,
and this stuff is super hard to measure.
So we knew that was going to be kind
of a long shot, but it was a goal. Uh,
we were obviously hopeful that it
was self sustaining enough. Uh,
from the beginning we knew that this was
not something that was likely to make a
lot of money. Uh, and we were kind of
hoping for breakeven. That was our,
that was our expectation was breakeven
was a, was a, a best case scenario.
Um, and for me, I think, uh,
one thing that I was,
I was really excited about it was kind
of inspiring other developers to approach
these subjects and to hire more diverse
teams and to encourage that sort of a
change in the industry. Because I
can make a game and that's great. Uh,
and it can have an impact.
But if I can encourage other
people to do this as well,
then that should have a bigger
impact than I could have by myself.
So to me that was, that was a pretty
big, uh, goal from the beginning.
So, uh, the game's been out for a week.
Early results are that the people that
actually played the game because there
are lots of people that would be happy
to tell you what they think about the
game, but have not
played the game. Uh, the,
the majority of people who played the
game and actually know what they're
talking about, uh, in relationship
to the south side of Chicago. Um,
think that we did a good job of
representing a life on the south side.
And we've gotten lots of emails and
comments and blog posts and tweets and
reviews from people who are from the
south side who talked about how it
represented their experience
and, uh, some critiques for sure,
but also a lot of, uh, a lot of
positivity about the representation.
And like almost across the board,
everyone was saying this is something
that needed to be done and it's a,
it's a kind of stepping stone towards
better things that will come later. Um,
so that was very positive and reassuring.
We've also got lots of other stuff,
uh, that was, uh, very, um,
highly offensive and racist,
uh,
posted to our forums and in
comments on all sorts of things. Uh,
and the scale of it was a little
bit more than we were expecting. Uh,
but we kind of knew from the beginning
we were gonna be getting some of that.
I was just kind of hoping that
it would be a little less than,
than what we ended up
getting. Um, but yeah,
so for starting conversations,
uh, before we launched,
another thing that happened at some of
the conventions that we went to, uh,
we would be walking around, uh, not
at our booth, not near our booth.
And we would hear people talking about
the game and talking about the characters
and talking about what would it be
like if this was our experience, if,
if we had grown up in this situation.
Um,
and I think in particular
the gaming audience, uh,
who oftentimes,
uh,
we'll start giant campaigns about how
we have to get politics out of games and
we have to stop being so political
and all of this other stuff. Uh, to,
to know that these conversations were
happening at a gaming convention I think
was really a great thing to have happen.
And I think it was important.
And I think the,
uh,
the hopeful shift that we're going to
get is that as more people are having
these serious discussions in games,
that it becomes more normal to be talking
about this stuff and to be talking
about the real issues that are happening
in the games industry around race and
representation. Uh, and if we
can be a part of starting that,
I think that's a good thing.
Um,
from the beginning until now,
we've had over 75 articles and interviews,
unique articles and interviews across
all these different types of medium, um,
way more than I ever
expected when we started. Uh,
and I think probably looking at our sales,
these will most likely have a bigger
impact on starting conversations than the
actual game.
Well,
because of the number of people that
are going to be playing the game versus
seeing a kind of media coverage of it.
Um,
although there's lots of youtube videos
that are getting views of like the full
game being played.
So it's entirely possible that people
will get some out of that as well. Uh,
but yeah,
I think,
I think this is probably the biggest
place that we have been able to actually
start conversations and we've been
doing it at consumer shows and,
and trade events and,
and that sort of thing.
So getting some conversations
out of that. So for this, uh,
I don't know that we can claim anything
specific really. We're only a week out.
Um, hopefully we've had an impact through
the conversations that we started.
And we're also, uh, working with
a professor at Northwestern now,
uh, to do psych studies on the game and
talk about the efficacy of the game to
educate people and to increase empathy.
And those things I think are ways that
we can find out if we actually have the
impact that we're hoping to have. And
if we can find out that, uh, you know,
people are walking away from this
with an understanding that then is
transformative to their actions
later. Uh, that's, that's the hope.
So, uh, financially, uh, I
don't think we're there yet.
We definitely haven't recouped the
investment that we've put into it. Um,
and again, that was kind
of a long shot anyway. Uh,
but I think there are two big reasons why,
um,
and it was important design
decisions that we made very early on,
uh,
that were important to us to tell
the story that we want it to tell a.
So the first one is this narrative
pacing, um, is, as I said,
realistic on the slide. You can read
that as slow. Uh, and generally speaking,
gamers are looking for fast things.
They're looking for more stuff on screen,
more particle effects,
more exciting, you know,
sound effects and everything
going crazy all the time. Uh,
and that wasn't the story that we
wanted to tell and it wasn't, uh,
going to be doing the people that we
interviewed any justice by telling the
story in that way.
Um,
and so we made a conscious choice
at the beginning to not do this,
but it kind of put us at odds with
our primary demographic that we were
advertising in the game too. Um, and
so I think that definitely contributed.
The other big thing, uh, was we take
away control from the player a lot.
Uh, and this was intentional
and it became, uh,
a little bit more. Um, we,
we did it a lot more as
the project went on, uh,
in particular because of
a game called spent. Uh,
so if any of you've heard of the game,
basically it's a web game wherein you're
given a certain allotment of money,
uh, and it's essentially equivalent
to a minimum wage job or,
or even a little bit less. Uh, and you
have to decide how to spend your money.
And the idea is to increase empathy with
people who are homeless or people who
are poor. Uh, by saying like,
Hey, look, this is really hard.
If you make these choices,
you're gonna make bad choices or
you're not going to be able to afford
everything and you're going to have to
figure out what you value the most. Right.
Uh,
the interesting thing that came out of
this was someone did a psych study after
the game came out and they ran it with
people who had predispositions against
poor people, uh, and
thought, you know, oh,
they're just making bad choices in
life and this is their own fault. Uh,
and after playing the game,
they found that they actually were more
inclined to believe that than they were
before they had played the game.
And the reasoning that the
psychologist to Deuce, um,
was that the game was designed in such
a way that it presented you with lots of
choices.
And so if you were playing through the
game and you made all these choices and
you got to a certain stage and
the game said, Oh, you lost,
you spent all your money, now you're poor
and homeless, right? Uh, you went, oh,
well I just, I should have just made this
other choice over there. Well, oh, well,
but somebody would have
made that choice in like,
why didn't they make that choice? And you
just kind of project this idea of, well,
if I had just made these choices,
everything would've been fine.
Maybe I didn't make the
right one in this situation,
but there was a right choice and I should
have made it and they should have as
well. Um, and so that kind
of tied in this idea of like,
if I have complete control of a
situation and something goes wrong,
then I just made a wrong choice as
opposed to sometimes there are things that
are outside of my control and there's
nothing I can do about it. And so we,
we did a lot in the game, uh,
that you have no control over.
There is no right answer. There's no
choice that gets you out of a situation,
you're just in it now. Right.
Um, and Kamers do not like that.
They play games. Uh, I think a
lot of people play games. There's,
there's been a lot of kind of studies on
this and people play games because they
like having to,
you know,
having all these options and being able
to do what they want and being able to
have control of the character. And so
when you take that away, um, they don't,
they don't like it. That's strange.
Um, and so I think the, uh,
the expectation from our
side was, hey, you know,
we're making these choices intentionally
and people are going to figure it out
and they're going to realize why we made
these choices and they're going to be
okay with it. And, uh, I don't think it's,
I don't think it's quite
worked out that way. Um,
and I think those have led
to a lot of our, our, uh,
lack of financial success with the game
on the industry influence side.
Uh, we've definitely
contributed to the discussion.
This was a talk I gave
it at GDC last year,
which is the big game
developer conference.
And we've had a bunch of people talk to
us about their personal experiences and
how they're excited to see,
you know,
more people of Color in games and more
people of Color on development teams. Um,
and, and the work that we've done to
try to, to talk about the game and,
and to spread awareness about these
initiatives and that sort of thing.
So that's been really rewarding. Uh,
there was one particular point where, um,
there was a developer from Cameroon who
was at a convention with us and they
were telling us that they saw
our game get coverage, uh,
in games press and that they felt that
that meant people were actually okay
talking about black characters in games,
which is simultaneously really depressing.
That that had to be a thing that they,
uh, were aware of. But
then also, you know,
very rewarding that we were able to
kind of help give them confidence to,
you know,
talk about their game more with us press
and talk about it in that context. So,
yeah, I mean, I think this is the games
industry has had a long history of,
of issues around race and
representation and, uh,
there are more discussions happening now.
I think it still remains to be seen how
much people actually follow through on
that and not just talk about it. Um,
so we'll see. We'll see how that goes.
Hopefully sooner rather than
later. Uh, and going forward,
we're working with a nonprofit.
Uh,
we have two nonprofits that
we're partnered with. Uh,
this one in particular works
in, uh, high schools, uh,
to help kids who are at risk for joining
gangs or who have already joined. Um,
they're basically the last resort before
they get suspended from school. Uh,
and they're trying to convince them like,
Hey, we've been down this road before.
All the people who are
instructors and their program, uh,
used to be in gangs and they basically
say like, Hey, we've been down this path.
Here's how you can get out. Here's
how we can help you stay out. Um,
and here's how we can get you back in
school and get you on a road to success.
And to, you know, thrive and
lead a lead a good life. Um,
and so we're working with them to try to
get the game into schools to help kids
be able to talk about these experiences.
Um, and we're hoping to expand that.
And then again,
like I said,
we're working with a psychology professor
to hopefully figure out how effective
the game actually is and,
and what kind of impact it's actually
having so that we can speak to that, um,
in a, in a more direct way with
actual evidence about, you know,
here's a rigorous study that shows that
this is actually effective. Um, yeah,
so that is the overview.
Um,
and then we're going to do a Q
and a session I think now. Yeah.
Yeah.
Thanks.
First off, thank you for that, Michael.
We really appreciate sharing
your insight and you know,
going through the process of creating
that game. And now as Mike mentioned, a,
we definitely want to take some time to
field some questions from you guys. Um,
I know I have a couple in
mind. Um, I can start it off.
Would you guys definitely think of some
questions that we can start to get to.
Um, so for starters, I guess like who
was your intended audience for the game?
Like obviously I'm sure you're trying to
get it out to as many folks as possible,
but yeah, from the beginning and like
who was the initial intended audience?
Yeah, so this is something that's changed
over the, the development process.
When we started it was originally we want
to talk to people who are not from the
south side and, and give them an
exposure to this experience and,
and help them kind of engage with us
and talk about it in a personal way.
Uh, as the game went along, we
were talking to Tony in particular,
kept talking about all of his friends
wanting to play the game and getting
really excited about
playing the game. Um, and,
and working with reclaim our kids to talk
about using it in schools for kids who
are from the south side and west side.
Um,
and I think that became an additional
market that we were interested in,
in trying to get the game
too. And, and trying to, um,
develop some additional things for us.
So we actually did some play tests with
some kids from the south and west side,
uh, on a couple of occasions.
And one of the kids said, uh,
basically he had been held up a couple
of days previously and seeing it to
picked it again and the game was
kind of traumatic for him. Uh,
and so we added a mode basically right
before launch and that allows you to
disable the visual elements during
violence scenes and it just puts up texts
that says what's happening.
Um,
as a way to kind of give people who
are in this and have this as a personal
experience,
a little bit of space if they need it
to be able to experience the whole game
without,
you know,
having to be traumatically
reliving experiences that
you've potentially recently
had.
Got It. Got It. Yeah. Um,
also I was just curious about where
can we find this game if we wanted to
purchase it and also how much is the game.
Yeah. Uh, so the game is up
on our website, which is we
are Chicago game.com. Uh,
and it's normally $15.
It's like
there's an off right now. So Nice.
Very nice. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Cool.
Hi. Can you talk a little bit
about the assumptions, um,
that really came to light,
you know, when working with this writer
that kind of brought in an entirely new
perspective when developing the
story and also on that note,
can you talk a little bit about,
you know,
why you did choose a game as a medium
for this? Because I think this is a,
you know, a big topic of discussion
across media in general. But yeah,
really interested to
hear, you know, why game.
Sure. Yeah. So the, the
game thing first, uh,
we chose the game because
you're interacting, right?
Because you have to make choices.
You have to rationalize it to yourself.
You have to justify those in your own
mind and you're playing as a character.
So it's not necessarily the same
choices that you would make.
And we don't present you with
an unlimited set of options.
You still have some constraints
on how you can respond,
but those choices that you're
justifying personally to yourself,
even in the context of the character
are way more engaging than watching
somebody else do it.
And it also speaks to the
kind of judgements that a
lot of people pass, right?
If you're watching a documentary about
somebody who's living in a low income
neighborhood and you think, oh, they
just made bad choices, or you know,
if I was in that situation,
I would have done something differently.
A game basically says,
here are your choices.
Make some choice that you think is
better and see how it plays out. Right?
And so I think from that perspective,
if it's done well, again,
like spent as the model of, you know,
this is not how to do it. Right. Um, and,
and to be fair,
like we didn't know that that wasn't
how to do it until they did that.
And the s psych study came out.
So, um, it was an important, like,
kind of first step in that.
But I think if you do it right and you,
and you can textualize it correctly,
I think it can be way more impactful than,
than, uh, a film. And to the other
question about, um, uh, kind of,
uh,
a lot of the stuff came out of just
like mindset differences about like how
people are perceiving the things that
are happening. Um, and I, I think,
I'm trying to think of exactly
how to, how to say this, but like,
like basically we came into a
lot of situations thinking, okay,
these are terrifying experiences or
they're very traumatic experiences or
they're extremely exceptional experiences.
And,
and to realize and to really put yourself
in the position of actually these
happen frequently enough that
people are not, you know,
constantly in fear and they're
not constantly upset about
them. You know, I mean,
like, they might be upset
about them all the time,
but they're not afraid of
them all the time. Right.
Because it's just what you live in
now. Um, and, and I think that was, uh,
those sorts of realizations shaped how
we were talking about things in the
script and, and, and what things
we want it to talk about a lot.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Yeah.
How does the game, and like two
or three ways in which the game,
can you talk a little bit about that?
Uh,
so you mean from like a story
perspective or from, okay,
spoiler alerts. Uh, yeah. So, yeah.
Yeah. Um, yeah, let me see.
Let me see if I can figure out a way
to not spoil everything. Uh, yeah.
I don't know if I can. Um, uh,
so basically the set up for the story is
you're hanging out with your friends a
lot and they stop hanging out with you
and you don't know exactly what's going
on and you find out through
the course of the game, uh,
that they've joined rival
gangs essentially. Um,
and so you have to kind
of talk to them about,
you're trying to convince them that
they've made bad choices and that you want
to get them out. Um, and
they're telling you, hey,
I've made these choices for a reason.
Like I don't have any educational
going forward past high school.
I don't have any job opportunities
because of the situation that I'm in.
And because of my family, uh, there
were a lot of discussions about, um,
kind of family influences
where, you know, if your,
if your father or your
brother is involved in a gang,
you're assumed to be in
that as well and you're,
you're kind of excluded from a lot
of opportunities. And so, um, it's,
it's a lot about talking about these
kinds of reasons that people are choosing
to join s stuff and make these choices
that from the outside seem very odd and
end. Like, why would you make that
choice? Um, and so in the end, uh,
the game kind of concludes
with your friends, um,
having to reconcile the fact
that they're in rival gangs. Uh,
let me put it that way. And then,
uh, and you kind of frank too,
to keep everybody safe and mitigate
that as much as possible. Is that,
is that a good enough answer without
spoiling everything? Yeah. Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It would be.
Right, right, right. And, and I think,
so we made, we made a choice early on.
Part of it was from a kind of budget
constraint perspective of if we have to
make two different endings,
there's a lot of additional content and
a lot of additional things that we have
to create to make that happen. So we
didn't want to have a divergent ending.
But I think another part of it that came
in later was this idea of like there
some things that you just don't have
control over in your friends making these
choices are things you don't
have control over. So um,
a lot of that kind of came out
of the design decisions early on.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think the entire time you were talking
I was thinking like how do we get this
into the hands of that Hashtag
all lives matter crowd. Yeah.
And I'm curious like how you guys have
been thinking about getting the game into
the hands of people who will self
select out of wanting to play it.
Because to me,
that seems like one of the core
important audiences for this,
because as you said with the empathy and
the kind of ability to understand what
people go through it and not be able to
hand waves their experiences would be
really impactful for
this country as a whole.
Right, right. Totally agree. Yeah.
So originally our intention when we
started the project was to present this as
an interesting narrative experience and
to not talk about the fact that it's
talking about south side Chicago
and talking about, you know,
the African American experience
and in cities in Chicago or in, in,
in the United States.
Um,
and the hope was if we pitched it
enough as a narrative experience, uh,
that we could convince the audience
that plays narrative games,
which does have some overlap as we
found out at various conventions. Um,
there's a,
there's a fairly big game called a walking
dead telltale walking dead game. Um,
and it's kind of the game that started
a lot of the hype about narrative driven
games. Um, and the main
character is black. Um,
and there's a lot of discussion in the
game about kind of the way he's treated
because of his race.
Right.
And we literally had multiple people
come up to us while we were demoing the
game, uh, at various conventions
that would say like, oh,
the game wasn't about a black person
or he wasn't black or things like that.
And you're like,
how can you be making these statements?
Like this is a focal point of,
part of the story is that he's black and
he's being treated differently. So, um,
yeah,
I think it's a huge challenge to try to
figure out how to get it in their hands.
And,
and I think one thing that we kind
of realized was we didn't have,
we didn't have a way that we could
market the game that would make me feel
comfortable marketing it and that way and
still get it into that, that audience,
because we didn't want to paint the
neighborhood is always terrible.
Everything terrible all the time.
Right?
We wanted to talk about the
positive things that were happening.
We have great moments where you're sitting
down with your family and like kind
of having these familial experiences
and there's a poetry slam where you feel
very accomplished for being able to like
express yourself and talk about what's
happening in your life.
Um,
and so we wanted to make sure that the
game was not all negative all the time.
Uh,
and,
and the way that games generally are
marketed to people is high drama,
high action, lots of violence,
things happening all the time. Right?
And so to get it to that audience,
we had to do things that we weren't
comfortable doing. Um, and we didn't,
we never really figured out how to resolve
that, that situation. I do think, um,
really long answer, I really,
I do think that the, uh,
the reclaim our kids
getting it into schools, um,
is an interesting avenue to do
that. Um, I think a lot of like,
there's been talk about how a lot of
trolling and stuff online is like 12 year
olds and stuff, right? Um, and I
think if we can get it into schools,
not just on the south side of
Chicago, but across, you know,
the whole Chicago Public School
district or something to that effect,
I think those are ways that we can
start impacting, maybe not, you know,
the people who are already 20,
30 years old and our, you know,
racist and making comments
all over the place.
But if we can start a little bit younger
and, and reach a wider school audience,
I think that could be an avenue
that would, that would be effective.
I guess my question is at the
beginning of a lot of video, uh,
video games and even, um,
like movies or films. Yeah.
You always see the,
I guess the combination of why things
got this way or how it got that way. Hmm.
Um, I think between, uh,
either kids that are in the environment
or kids that are not in the environment,
I think that would be the main question
is like, okay, this is happening,
this is here. But how did this get, like,
why is this like this? How did this get
like this? What's the story behind it?
And I think with that you get
to be in a sense educational,
um, informative, which
is the same thing. Uh,
and you kind of move closer towards
the solution rather than just telling a
story for sure him.
And I want to know if that in the game
or if that was a part and like how deep
you went with that.
Yeah. Yeah. So our approach, we didn't do
kind of the upfront version of that. Um,
what we try to do is work it
into a lot of the conversations.
So when you're sitting at the park
and you're talking to your friends,
they'll talk about how they can't get
a job or they'll talk about a housing
discrimination or things
like that. Um, and they'll,
they'll bring up the kind of historical
reasons of how we got here with red
lining and housing discrimination
and, and, uh, you know,
the highway system that,
you know,
all that kind of stuff.
They'll talk about that
stuff in the context of the
problems that they're having
right now. Um, so that was our,
that was our kind of experiment to
see if we could get some of the, the
historical educational information
across in a more natural way for the
characters be talking
about it. Um, and I again,
just like study is going to be very
useful to find out if that was actually
effective.
If people actually got something out
of that or if they were just like,
that was a weird conversation, why would
you be talking about that? Um, but I,
I think that's, that's the approach that
we took and we're going to see if it,
if it was effective,
but to us it was about kind of telling
this consistent narrative story
throughout the,
the game experience and not theirs.
There's some games that kind of take
you out of the experience and say like,
and now we're going to play this video
or we're going to play this cinematic or
do something that doesn't seem like
it fits with the context of the game.
And we wanted to avoid that as much as
possible, like all the menus for the game.
Everything exists in
the world. Um, and the,
the idea was we want you to have this
kind of continuous experience of this
person's life so that you don't have
anything that you think like, oh,
well if I filled in that blank with a
better choice than I could have gotten out
of this. Right. Um, so that was kind of
our thought behind it. Um, and we're,
we're trying to get that kind of
educational information across. It's just,
Gosh, I think, um, I'm glad to hear that.
Yeah. Like baked into it and that's good.
Um, I think a lot of times, even sometimes
with my work or anybody else's work,
I think what lacks, um, or
what, what helps people,
I guess fully understand something or
fully understand what they're getting
ready to experience is context.
Right. And so, you know,
while you're talking about the kids
that were like making these insensitive
jokes or whatever,
right.
Sometimes I feel like if they were to
see almost like a trailer of like, okay,
like a piece of context,
then you can go, oh, okay,
maybe now I want to see, you
know, what this is about.
And I think what would spur people to
kind of jump into it rather than just
throwing them in the middle of, you
know, yeah. I haven't played it yet,
so I can't say what it is,
but it just feels like I need
for people to know, okay,
this people just aren't out here,
poor aren't out here.
Disadvantaged. Because they were like,
hey, I want to be the disadvantage. Right,
right, right. It's been
like this systematic things.
Yeah. I think that's the,
yeah. The length that I think you have
in there. I just want to, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Yeah. And I think
to, to that, uh, to that point,
we're hoping that the game essentially
mirrors our own process of,
of developing the game for the
players were, when I got started,
I didn't understand them
a lot of that context.
I didn't really know a lot of that detail,
but when I heard the stories that
people were telling, I was like,
this is really strange. Like, why is this
happening? Why is this the situation?
And that spurred me to find out more
and to do more research into and to read
more about it and think more about it.
Um,
and so we're hoping that the game kind
of gives you this like really high level.
Here's some stuff that's very interesting
that you should be thinking about and
then start those discussions and start
kind of a more in depth in depth research
project of sorts into that after
the fact. Right. So you can,
you can play the game and then go,
that was interesting.
I want to know about more about this
and look it up online or, you know,
find out more stuff. Yeah, thanks.
Thank you for that. Um, I know
we have a couple of minutes left.
Definitely want to get to
the last question over here.
So I was wondering what
sort of inspiration you took
from the current narrative
driven games that are out there right now,
like Firewatch and gone home and what
lessons you learned about keeping people
engaged with the interactive
elements of the game.
Yeah. Yeah. So gone home was
super inspirational for us. Um,
I think that the two biggest
inspirations were, uh,
well maybe three has gone home,
the walking dead. And then, um,
there was another game that's not exactly
narrative driven but it's cart life.
Um,
and cart life of the guy that was making
cart life was basically talking about
how he wanted the game mechanics to kind
of create in the player the emotions
that the character was experiencing.
So if the character was
experiencing something tedious,
the game play should be tedious to kind
of replicate that experience to the
player.
Um,
and so we did a couple of those things
with like setting the table and,
and like stuff at work that's
like really boring and monotonous,
but it kind of sets up these,
these bigger,
more dramatic things that
happened afterwards and kind
of give some contrast. Um,
and walking dead gave us a lot of
inspiration for a kind of character
development. And what was
the, what was a good, um,
kind of dynamics to have
between the player and the,
and the other characters in the story?
Uh, so we, we played a lot with that. Um,
and then,
uh,
gone home was a lot of
like kind of filling out
environmental storytelling and,
and things like that,
which we try to do. Um,
we didn't get as much in as we wanted,
but that was a big focus was trying to
tell a lot of things through what's on
somebody's desk or what's up on the wall
as opposed to just being very explicit
and put it in through voiceover
or, or voice acting. Um, so yeah,
there was, there were definitely
lots of inspirations. That aesthetic.
Yeah. Does that, yeah. A second
half was, what did you learn about
keeping people engaged
through interacting,
getting people engaged? Yeah. So, um, uh,
we have definitely
learned that play testers,
both,
uh,
like play testers that we organized and
playtesting at conventions is not a good
representation of what a
person at home and play as.
We have a lot of,
we had a lot of stuff that we had been
doing throughout development where we
were kind of saying like, okay, uh,
people are responding well to
this and this is working out well.
And then when we get to a release
and consumer reviews are out, um,
there were a lot of choices that we
made that again, like slower pacing and,
and things to that effect that did
not go over well with like consumer,
uh, response. Um,
but worked fine in our play tests or
worked fine on a convention for when they
were playing the game for 20 minutes.
Uh,
so we thought we'd learned a bunch of
stuff about how we could slow down the
pacing.
And then when we got it released,
we found out that a lot of people didn't
respond as well as we thought. Um,
so I don't know we have
a good solution for, uh,
like slower pacing or making
the narrative, um, move
in a more realistic pace.
Uh, but I do think it is kind of a, uh,
a process that the industry has to go
through where we don't really have an
audience that is looking for this
and games and the people who would be
interested in this don't think
of themselves as gamers. Um,
and so I think we're at a
stage now where it's just,
we're so early on that we need more games
like this to come out and to encourage
other people to get into games and
to be interested in, in games, uh,
so that we can kind of grow that audience
and make it an actual market that we
can target.